hallo mein Name ist Luca heute schauen
wir mal wieder auf zdft
wir sind wieder auf der Seite z0r die
Seite auf der wir schon die ein oder
andere tolle Erfahrung gemacht haben
wir können hier unten einfach mal auf
random klicken und dann bekommen wir
schon einen
[Musik]
ich frage mich immer wieder
geht's noch schneller
ich komme gar nicht mehr hinterher der
Sinn dieser Website ist quasi dass wir
unten auf random klicken können und dann
bekommen wir eine neue Website das heißt
wenn ich auf random klicke seht ihr
schon wir haben nun eine Website die uns
sagt dass wir einen weißen Screen haben
[Musik]
wow
wow wow
das hört sich irgendwie an wie so ein
Medley von irgend so einer Anime Serie
oder
okay
was das ist will ich das ist
zu scharf und hier meine Damen und
Alter wenn man nur auf den Beginn der
Schlange die ganze Zeit schaut dann wird
das ja übelst crazy nach Hause
[Musik]
kriegt wieder auf random und
was ist das für ein Scheiß
[Musik]
der nächste Website haben wir hier ein
eine Ananas tatsächlich die hier die
was mache ich hier eigentlich was das
hier sein soll
verstehe ich gerade auch nicht so ganz
oh Wasserfälle okay wir haben den
Tiefpunkt erreicht wir haben eine fette
Kuh die auf ihrem Euter rumhüpft
[Musik]
muss ich da noch irgendwas zu sagen ich
klicke jetzt auf nächste wenn das
nächste übel scheiße ist dann
ja ist es halt übel scheiße
[Musik]
du hast ein scheiß
was Einschalten so beim nächsten haben
wir jetzt
[Musik]
was ist das
was mache ich hier ist das aus Toy Story
oder ist das aus Team Fortress 2 oder
oder woher kommt das wahrscheinlich was
komplett anderes und ich habe überhaupt
keine Ahnung gerade der nächste Website
haben wir hier einen
wenn du denkst ist überhaupt nicht mehr
schlimmer kommen kann
[Musik]
sowas
wow
cool das
ist hammer
random
next oh ein Wackelpudding der auf seinem
Weg ist über die Straße und da sind
Sterne und der sieht traurig aus
ja
nothing wir haben was Tolles
wow
ist wunderschön ich habe Angst dass
YouTube jetzt das Video wieder sperrt
weil letztens als ich diesen
wie hieß das noch mal ich verlinke euch
das Video mal hier da könnt ihr euch das
angucken da wird nämlich das Video
gesperrt weil da irgendwie Titten zu
sehen Mann was aber nicht stimmt weil
ich die extra zensiert habe und Youtube
sagt trotzdem hey hey sonst sind wir
jetzt beenden ich lass das jetzt hier
absichtlich drin denn mir ist egal was
ihr sagt und jetzt kommen wir auch schon
zur letzten Sache die zwei kriege ich
auf random und wir kriegen
damit beende ich dir das Video